alors poussée que dans cette émission
n'a une coutume qui est de demander à
des gens dans la rue ce qu'ils pensent
de notre invité est ce que tu es prêt à
supporter ça j'en ai rien vu à tout
accord le pire est un ami mais je crois
pas que ça soit le pays a good bien
un grand bonhomme pour vous oui c'est
quelqu'un que j'apprécie énormément
chauffe qu'il a des tas de bonnes idées
il est très sensible heureusement qu'à
des gens comme lui si vous le trouvez
supérieurement intelligent honnêtement
oui je trouve que j admire énormément il
est extrêmement intelligent et voyez que
son oeuvre restera appelé à surnom sur
mon but je pense que ça restera très
très bien s'il y avait des centaines de
gens comme lui en politique ce sera pas
mal trouvé très intelligent assez web au
moins ça super microbes intelligent oui
brillant oui je pense est intéressante
pour vous je trouve aussi une manière de
faire qui nous paraît intéressant c'est
relativement bien écrit un homme qui
restera pour lui certainement d'ailleurs
il est je crois classée numéro un parmi
les personnalités mondiales notamment
entendez sur d'autres continents
notamment aux états unis
vous pouvez qui passe bien la télévision
bah il passe d'une façon originale à sa
manière
oui qui décrit bien écoutez je n'ai rien
lu de lui pour être franche vous admirez
tout de même certainement
il voit pas
les délires 20 m tu as raté l'académie
parce que tu as dit au moment où tu
allais peut-être y rentrer et tu as fait
une publicité pour vespa en disant que
tu ferais rentrée le mauvaise pas dans
le dictionnaire
mais là ce soir est ce que finalement
c'est pas mieux que l'académie bah oui
c'est évident mais si j'entre à
l'alcoolémie ça ne surprendra personne
tous voulaient entre l'académie pour
faire plaisir à mon vieux père mon père
et mes rares dont 48 en raison du
retrait est ce que à ton avis de qui
parle et les gens qu'on vient de voir
je me suis posé et devance aussi
peut-être de l'autre on va voir de qui
parlez alors son oeuvre restera appelé
assurent non surement but which parce
que ça restera oui oui c'est de qui on
parle là mm jacques yves cousteau
quand les gens et dernier
par le biais de jean edern hallier lin
lin dan est pas question
vous le trouvez brillant oui par le bien
des gens et d'un allié ah non donc vous
pensez que jean edern hallier est un
homme qui restera non nous parlions plus
tôt pas le temps des grands bonhommes
pour vous jean-edern hallier pardon
jean-edern hallier est un grand bonhomme
pour vous donc lié vous parlez de qui là
madame va vous parler du commandant
cousteau je vous parle de gens et dans
l'allier vous en pensez quoi
alliez passer pour celui qui a quitté
haïti qui se bat là l'enfant côté de
vous à moi je trouve que la france est
une poubelle et qu'on reçoit n'importe
qui n'importe quoi
les baby blacks alors là là c'est un
sketch formidable la statue est
absolument venir par son client
enfin en vidéo les complimente a
toujours le temps et en jean edern faut
le savoir les corrections de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux